[Musik]
mehr als fünf monate krieg in der
ukraine und wir wollen heute zur
abwechslung in den letzten wochen mit
positiven bilder anfang mit einer
ukrainischen flagge die hier gehisst
wurde auf der schlange insel die
schlangen insel einem jahr nur zwei
fußballfelder großer brocken im
schwarzen meer der aber extrem
strategisch wichtig ist und deshalb
bereits am ersten kriegstag von russland
besetzt wurde
russische truppen sind hier gelandet
haben hier versuchen wir zeigen dass
technologie auf der karte die ukraine
nämlich den hafen von odessa vor allem
abzuschneiden vom rest des schwarzen
meeres und nach fünf monaten schwerer
ukrainischer bombardements ist die
russische armee endlich abgezogen in der
letzten woche und es hat noch weitere
tage gedauert ehe die ukraine sich dann
auch getraut haben selbst wieder in die
völlig zerstörte wir sehen dass links
und rechts alle häuser völlig zerstört
auf die völlig zerstörte insel
zurückzukehren und dann ihre eigene
flagge wieder zu wissen wir sehen uns
noch mal ganz kurz an wo die schlangen
insel sich befindet das ist wie gesagt
ein kleiner felsbrocken hier unten etwa
kurz vor ja schon fast vor rumänien kann
man sagen und mit diesem kleinen
felsbrocken hatte es russland geschafft
in den letzten monaten eben über die
krim die ja schon seit 2014 besetzt ist
und in diesen besetzten brocken den
hafen von odessa und damit eben
millionen tonnen getreide aufzuhalten
abzuhalten davon nach afrika und in
andere kontinente und gegen verschifft
zu werden ein riesiger hungerkatastrophe
droht deshalb und jetzt zumindest ist
russland hier abgezogen unter schwerem
feuer die ukraine haben das dort
zurückerobert und die frage ist ob das
reicht um diesen diesen diesen
belagerung skrtel dort zu brechen wir
müssen aber auch leider wieder in den
osten der ukraine gucken dort gehen die
schweren kämpfe weiter und auch wenn
russland gestern eine feuerpause
angekündigt hat ist davon natürlich
nichts zu sehen auf dem feld das war
wieder mal eine propagandalüge wir haben
neue vorstöße hier jetzt nachdem region
luhansk mit der großstadt des titels
komplett erobert wurde versucht russland
jetzt in richtung slogans vorzurücken
und zwar einmal aus norden und einmal
aus osten dort haben wir neue vorstöße
und wir haben auch aufnahmen dazu was
ganz spannend ist weil ja wie gesagt das
russische verteidigungsministerium
behauptet die leute hatten durften jetzt
briefe schreiben die durften sich jetzt
mal ein bisschen ausruhen luft pakete
aus der heimat empfangen
wirklichkeit sehen wir hier die
wirklichkeit von russischen
propagandisten vor ort die sie im
hubschrauber in der luft wir sind
schwere artillerie die transportiert
wird und wir sind immer mehr lkw die
hier an die an die front fahren hier
transport lkw auf der rechten seite
panzer transporter die wirklichkeit ist
also dass die russen sich darauf
vorbereiten jetzt in donetzk wieder
vorzurücken also auf kammerchors kauf
sowie ganz die letzten großen städte
dort von der ukraine gehalten werden
dass also die realität aus dem
kampfgebiet während moskau erzielt man
hätte jetzt ja mal aus humanitären
gründen oder was auch immer eine pause
eingelegt so also die realität hier im
kampfgebiet wir wollen uns noch mal
ansehen die ukraine haben etwas neues
veröffentlicht und zwar warten sie ja
händeringend auf westliche waffen auf
hightech waffen aus dem westen aber sie
behelfen sich jetzt auch selber hier zum
ersten mal von den ukrainern eine eigene
kamikaze drohen also eine sogenannte
selbstmord drohne die eben über jetzt
hier fliegt das ziel erreicht und dann
eben auf das ziel nieder stürzten mit
einer sprengladung an bord diese drohne
wurde von den ukrainern selber
entwickelt und wir sehen die hier bei
einem ihrer ersten start die wird noch
getestet so eine art ja so eine art
katapult wird hier benutzt um sie
abzuschießen angeblich kann diese drohne
wir wissen sicher haben es muss von den
ukrainern gehört 20 kilometer weit
fliegen und hat einen 25 kilo schweren
sprengkopf und wir sehen die drohne ist
gleich wieder da ist sie da kommt sie
hier sehen wir sowieso vorbei fliegt das
heißt die ukraine versuche mir zu zeigen
wie sie das teil steuern können wie sie
es auch relativ genau steuern können
gucken uns das sozusagen bis weiter
vorne an und sehen wie dort die drohne
immer wieder getestet wird angeblich
wird diese drohne jetzt produziert und
ergebnis soll sie auf russische ziele
auch im osten genutzt werden um eben
dort das blatt etwas zu wenden
schlussendlich wollen wir uns wieder
ansehen welche unterstützungen aus dem
westen kommt und da gibt es auch neue
bilder deutschland weigert sich
weiterhin transportkapazitäten der
ukraine zur verfügung zu stellen also
vor allem transportpanzer der fuchs
wurde gestern auch noch von der
bundesregierung noch mal abgelehnt zu
liefern andere länder sind da ganz
anders auch europäische länder und auch
länder mit westlichen gerät hier sehen
wir neue aufnahmen von dem so genannten
iveco lmv der wurde aus italien
geliefert und ist jetzt erstmals
angekommen in den dienst der
ukrainischen armee wir sehen wie die
ukraine hier diese iveco sich angucken
militärische fahrzeuge eben gerade
schutz fahrzeuge wir sehen vielleicht um
auch drauf noch einmal die waffe die
hier darauf ist und wir sehen hier die
schwere panzerung dieses fahrzeuges man
muss allerdings sagen dieses fahrzeug
kommt mit einem kleinen wermutstropfen
denn bevor italien der ukraine jetzt
vielleicht fünf vielleicht zehn davon
zur verfügung gestellt hat hat italien
240 davon an russland verkauft insofern
werden hier jetzt beide seiten geliefert
beliefert von italien man versucht
vielleicht ein schlechtes gewissen damit
so ein bisschen weg zu machen auf jeden
fall auch italien liefert gepanzerte
fahrzeuge deutschland bislang weiterhin
nicht